a day after the u.s authorized second
booster shots for those over age 50
president joe biden rolled up his sleeve
and made a fresh pitch to americans
we're now in a new moment in this
pandemic
does not mean that covet 19 is over
it means that covet 19 no longer
controls our lives that's what it means
fourth shots are now seen as the best
defense for older and more vulnerable
people in the u.s they're rolling out at
a confusing time case numbers have
plummeted hospitalizations are at their
lowest point in two years it's hard to
tell people that doing something now is
really going to help you
weeks months
maybe even years down the line
there's reason for concern the omicron
ba2 subvariant is now dominant in the
u.s and cases are starting to tick back
up yet millions remain vulnerable
undeterred by the nearly 1 million
pandemic deaths to date today less than
70 percent of eligible americans are
fully vaccinated with two doses and only
46.5 percent have received a booster
dose this really does beg the question
where should we focus our limited
resources is it on providing fourth
doses or is it on other measures for
example making sure we vaccinate people
who may not have even had a single dose
yet
at the same time the once world-leading
u.s response has effectively run dry
congress has not approved funding to
cover the cost of future covid testing
treatment or vaccine doses congress has
to provide the funding america needs to
continue to fight cover 19. yet it may
be tough to convince americans to keep
up the fight
two years in and during a welcome
reprieve in cases many feel like they're
done with the pandemic even if it's not
done with them
jackson prosko global news washington